Microscopes are an essential tool for
biologists to see the tiny things they
study. But no matter how much you zoom
in with a microscope, some things are
just really hard to see. This is partly
because when you look at something
under a microscope, a lot of things are
pretty much the same color. This is
where fluorescence microscopy comes in.
More than 50 years ago, scientists
found a special protein in some
jellyfish that make them glow under
ultraviolet light. This protein, named
green fluorescent protein, or GFP,
changes shape when hit by the right
color of light. This change in
structure makes GFP fluoresce. It
absorbs ultraviolet light and shines
out green light. With this discovery,
the way scientists use microscopy was
changed forever. How? Well, you might
be familiar with the traditional light
microscope. You've got your sample on a
stage, a bumble bee in this case, and a
lamp sends white light up through the
stage to your eye, with some lenses for
magnification in between. But now we
want to specifically look at the brain
of this bumble bee. With light
microscopy, we can't really tell the
difference between different
structures. So let's take a different
bumble bee, one where we've labeled the
brain with GFP. Under white light, it
doesn't look like much. But now we add
a filter that only lets the right
wavelength, or color, of light through.
GFP absorbs this color of light and
glows. To make the picture as clear as
possible, we add one more filter so
only the green light reaches our eyes,
and now we can see the bumble bee brain
as clear as day. Since the discovery of
GFP, a whole rainbow of different
fluorescent proteins have been
engineered: red, orange, yellow, blue
and more. By using multiple fluorescent
proteins to color different parts of a
sample, we can very clearly see
whatever it is we might be looking for.